Bonjour à tous !
Bienvenue pour cette nouvelle journée,
nous sommes le mardi 21 mai
et il est 9h00.
J'espère que vous êtes en forme !
En tout cas, moi je suis ravie de vous retrouver.
Au programme aujourd'hui, une matinale rock des années 70
et cet après-midi, nous continuerons la lecture
du roman "La nuit des temps" de Barjavel.
Et c'est l'heure d'entamer notre matinale rock des 70's
avec le premier album des Run On Wire
qui a été au début de sa décénie le groupe
qui a révolutionné le rock anglais
et ils viennent tout droit de Brighton.
Merci papa pour cette découverte, ça c'était du rock !
Nous allons maintenant faire un petit point météo.
Nous sommes donc au jour 782,
et selon mes calculs, une tempête de force 4
devrait arriver entre 12h00 et 13h30
avec une première phase d'impulsion assez violente
qui devrait durer une dizaine de minutes,
et une deuxième phase qui devrait durer environ 3h.
Surtout, soyez très prudents,
et n'oubliez pas d'éteindre complètement vos appareils électriques.
avant la première phase.
Je répète :
une tempête de force 4
dans deux à trois heures.
Prenez soin de vous.
Et si vous m'entendez, contactez-moi
sur les fréquences 89.6
92.4, 96.3, 101.1.
Si quelqu'un m'entend, je vous en supplie...
contactez-moi.
C'est ici, faut être très concentré. C'est tes conseils qui sont pas fous.
Ahah ! Tu sais quoi, tu vas te débrouiller tout seul et puis c'est tout.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais.
Et bah regarde comment je me débrouille.
Et stop stop. Arrête, j'ai pas envie d'être sourde.
Tu sais quoi, un jour tu sera fière de moi.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais.
Tiens, au lieu de faire la maline.
À ton tour.
Non, j'ai pas envie de jouer.
Allez, s'il te plaît.
Mais pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il faut que...
Ici Alice.
Je suis de retour avec vous,
j'espère que tout le monde va bien.
J'ai le regret de vous annoncer que
l'intervalle entre les tempêtes se réduit à vue d'oeil,
passant à moins de deux jours.
Deux jours, c'est l'enfer.
Je vais vous laisser en musique.
Prenez soin de vous.
Allô ?
Quelqu'un m'entend ?